Es ist so dieses Stomp-Phänomen. So, das ist, man denkt sich, ach geil, wir können richtig gut Musik machen, wir würden mir keine Show anschauen. Zeit für Freundschaft bereit, wir sind Freunde für alles. Für ein kurzes Lied, das wir dann durch Dialog unterbrochen würden. Gott sei Dank! Zeit für alle zwei. Wiegeber, frisch und fertig, Florin Tietze. Heute ist auch ein Gegen, heute ist nicht Stefan und Florentin, sondern Stefan gegen Florentin. Witzel, will ich mir wieder wünschen. Wir stehen gegenüber, der kompetitive Gedanke ist immer noch heiß dabei. Ich finde, es ist mir seit Monaten zu harmonisch, zu wenig gegen. Heute wird gerieben, wir reiben uns aneinander. In einem Podcast wird gestritten. Ja, bei uns nicht. Auf einem lustigen Podcast gibt es so Streits. Ja.
Ein grosser Podcast möchte ich jetzt nicht erwähnen, da haben die sich neulich gestritten. Und dann habe ich das, ich habe das wirklich so, wie so, wenn so Eltern streiten. Weil man hat ja eh schon diese parasoziale, es gibt dieses Meme-Foto, zwei Freunde reden auf einem Plakat miteinander und man sitzt da vor, das ist so als Verbindung des Podcasts, dann kann ich mitreden, sitzt aber irgendwie ein Teil in der Gruppe, aber auch nicht richtig, weil es gibt halt den einen Kanal nur. Und diese Beziehung macht es aber irgendwie so wie so Eltern, die streiten und man würde gerne was sagen und sagen, ne, aber man wird selber ganz still, man sitzt in der U-Bahn und so ein peinliches Schwein. Anders als sonst, wo man die ganze Zeit mitredet und merkt, warum reden die nicht? Ja. Aber ich bin ja immer der, der, ich bin ja pro Streit, ich habe ja kein Problem. Debattenkultur. Das Nervigste für mich ist immer, wenn man irgendwie unter Leuten ist und man diskutiert mit jemandem und dann sagt ein Dritter, hör doch auf zu streiten. So, das hasse ich so. Nee, es ist einfach ein angeregter Austausch und das muss man auch ertragen können und das passt schon. Aber ich glaube, wirklich einen Streit hatte ich glaube ich vielleicht ein, zwei Mal in meinem Leben und ich könnte es auch nicht wirklich, zu sagen so, du immer mit deinem, du hast dich ja nie für mich interessiert. Wann hat es zum letzten Streit deines Lebens? Wirklich nie, wirklich nie. Wir haben uns noch nie gestritten. Ich käme mir da zu dumm vor, auch mit so einem Streit, mit so einem Hör, hör mal mit deiner, du immer mit deiner ewigen Leier.
Mir fehlen da die Vokabeln, glaube ich, einfach so. Ich würde dann immer so neben die Kamera schauen.
Aber man kann mit dir hitzig diskutieren.
Hitzig diskutieren, auf jeden Fall. Aber wirklich, also ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass ich immer sachlich bin, aber wirklich so ein harter Streit, wo es eskaliert, du kannst dich ja mal keinem benehmen. Ich werfe dir mal was für einen Latz, da habe ich glaube ich auch nicht die richtige Stimmlage dafür, da kenne ich mich auch dumm vor. Nee, man merkt anhand, wie du streitest, woher du von Streitz immer gehört hast. Nämlich so aus der Literatur oder so.
Und dann benutzt du so Wörter, die man nicht mehr benutzt. Ja, und ich glaube, ich hatte bis jetzt auch einfach wenig gute Streits in meinem Leben. Ich erinnere mich an einen guten Schulfreund von mir, der auch in der gleichen Siedlung gewohnt hat wie ich. Und wir haben zusammen Pokémon gespielt und es gab eine hitzige Debatte über Pokémon. Warum? Ich habe gesagt, dein Pokémon ist schlecht gegen den Trainer. Und er sagte, nein, nein doch ist er und er sagt, nein, der ist schlecht, das Element ist falsch und dann war der so sauer, dass der aufgestanden ist, gegangen ist, aber er ist nicht zu sich nach Hause gegangen, sondern er ist um das Haus meiner Eltern immer wieder drumrum gelaufen. Ist es gerade ein Flex dafür, dass man um das Haus seiner Eltern herumgehen konnte? Ja gut, ich meine es war ungefähr, du kommst, wenn du zügig läufst, bist du in 20 Minuten drumherum. Und irgendwann habe ich das gemerkt und war offenbar... Wenn dich die Hunde nicht erwischen. Ich meine, gut, du musst durch den See durchschwimmen und so alles. Und das Labyrinth. Durch das riesige Labyrinth und die Giraffen, je nachdem wann die gefüttert werden. Und ich habe immer gesehen, wie er ums Haus geht und ich fand das so komisch, dieses ich entziehe mich der Situation, aber ich bleibe trotzdem in der Nähe. Vielleicht ist es dieses, du kennst ja dieses Zählen, bis zehn kenne ich. Und dieses, ich möchte eigentlich, dass die Person sich entschuldigt, dafür möchte ich mich anbieten. Also ich, dramaturgisch entziehe ich mich der Person, aber ich bin trotzdem noch in Reichweite für eine Entschuldigung. Also dieses, wenn man langsam den Raum verlässt und möchte, dass die Person sagt, ach, jetzt bleibt doch noch so. Und das halt lange aufrechterhalten. Das war so ganz merkwürdig. Ich bewundere, dass du keine Streitkultur hast und das nicht machst. Und ich finde es vielleicht auch seltsam und vielleicht auch nicht gut. Kann sein, kann gut sein. Vielleicht ist es auch heilsam, sozusagen mal die Emotionen rauszulassen. Ich will zu sehr Dinge rational klären. Zum Beispiel war ich letztens mit dem Fahrrad unterwegs und Verkehr ist ja ein großes Thema, wir haben darüber gesprochen, die Geste und Kreisverkehr und alles und dann bin ich links abbieger und dann ist so eine mittelalte Frau relativ langsam über die Ampel gegangen und ich bin aber links abgebogen und dann war so die Situation, ah, noch vor oder hinter sie und dann bin ich relativ knapp hinter ihr gefahren, um sie nicht umzufahren. Und dann hat sie gesagt, das ist aber nicht nett. Und dann bin ich wirklich stehen geblieben und habe gesagt, was meinen Sie? Und sie so, ja, ich habe ja grün. Und dann ist sie weitergelaufen. Und dann bin ich wirklich ihr langsam hinterher gefahren und habe gesagt, ja, aber, ja, aber, ja, aber, sie verstehen schon, ich bin Linksabbieger, ich muss abbiegen, während sie grün haben. Es geht nicht anders. Nur weil sie grün haben, heißt es nicht, dass niemand über diese und sie wird so schneller holt das Pfefferspray langsam raus und nicht so. Nein, aber sie war wirklich wütend und hat mir den Rücken gekehrt und ist weggelaufen. Und ich wollte das einfach klären. Ich wollte einfach so, was genau war das Problem?
Boah, ich hasse das. Und es ist natürlich, ich weiß, dass das nicht konstruktiv ist und die Frau noch mehr belastet und so, alles klar. Aber ich finde das so unangenehm, so dieses, wenn er schon hat, sagt er, und dann fährt man weg und ich so, nee, lass uns kurz drüber reden. Nach deiner Logik, wir hatten hier die Diskussion, ich nehme Anspruch auf meinen Bahnbonus, auf mein Recht. Ja. Ich bin sozusagen, die Inanspruchnahme des Bahnbonusplatzes ist ja das Linksabbiegen, ich habe grün, es ist trotzdem, geht halt diese Frau da lang und so. So eine ältere Frau, sie braucht Zeit, wahrscheinlich ist sie auch erschrocken, hat nicht mehr die spatial awareness, die du hast. Nein, ja, okay. Egal, wie auch immer, jedenfalls dann, nach deiner Logik, sei das Arschloch, sei dann der rüpelhafte Rüpelmann und dann fahr rum und zeig den Mittelfinger und beschwer dich nochmal und hab die Hand an der Klingel und sei nicht der, entschuldigen Sie, aber ich hab alles richtig gemacht. Ja, sei das Arschloch, okay, verstehe ich, sei das Arschloch, wenn die Situation klar ist, dann sei das Arschloch.
Aber stell dir vor, diese Frau läuft jeden Tag über grüne Ampeln und regt sich jeden Tag auf, dass Leute über diese Strasse fahren und ärgert sich. Und ich denke mir so, könnte man das denn nicht einfach mal klären? War nicht das Thema, du bist zu dicht an ihr langgefahren? Das war der Auslöser auf jeden Fall. Und na klar, ich verstehe auch, ich gehe auch so weit, dass ich sage, dieses Ich-hab-Grün ist vielleicht nur eine Übersprungshandlung und eine Rationalisierung eines Gefühls, ich fühle mich bedroht und guckt euch, ich hab Grün, obwohl es eigentlich keinen Sinn ergibt. Sie hat Vorfahrt, Gang. Ja, hat sie ja auch, ich bin ja auch hinter ihr gefahren, aber ich verstehe schon, aber das glaube ich, und ich sage nicht, dass meine Methode besser ist, und deswegen stimme ich dir zu, dass es vielleicht besser wäre, sich kurz zu streiten und es dann liegen zu lassen. Ich denke immer so, Moment, wir können das ja auflösen, wenn wir das
jetzt einfach nur ausdiskutieren. Und ich bin
gerne der, der am Ende Unrecht hat, am Ende
dieser Diskussion, aber ich würde es gerne lösen, weil so
gehen wir beide in die Welt hinaus,
diese Frau und ich, und beide denken sich,
was da passiert, Ärger, Wut
in uns drin, aber es ist
nicht aufgelöst so. Deswegen, ich denke mir,
man muss auflösen, aber am Ende
Sie hat diese Agro-Range
um sich herum,
bewegt sich legal als Fußgängerin
Und Es ist nicht aufgelöst so. Deswegen, ich denke mir, man muss auflösen, aber am Ende ... Sie hat diese Agro-Range um sich herum, bewegt sich legal als Fußgängerin durch die Welt. Als Fußgängerin, aber fortgeschrittenen Alters. Und sie fühlt sich, weil du da in dieser Range reingekommen bist, als angegriffenes Opfer. Absolut, das verstehe ich total. Sie denkt, ah, ich kann bald nicht mehr raus, sonst werde ich über den Haufen gefahren. Das verstehe ich auf einer emotionalen Ebene total, aber ich finde, man muss ja Emotionen auch einbetten in klare Logik. In klare Logik. In klare Ration. Du darfst, du hast ja deine Räume für Wut, aber wenn das einfach so, das System so ist und das aus gutem Grund so geregelt ist, dann finde ich, musst du deinen Wutraum auch einschränken. So, und jetzt haben wir es doch, du streitest nie, weil du deine Emotionen hinter deiner messerscharfen Ratio versteckst. Und das macht Leute, weil ich bin ähnlich, das macht Leute in deinem Umfeld wahnsinnig. In meinem nämlich auch, wenn du immer mit Ratio kommst, dann hörst du wahrscheinlich auch häufig den Satz, und ich finde den total spannend, ja, aber lass doch mal meine, ignorier doch meine Gefühle nicht. Ja, okay.
Und ich mag, ich finde das so spannend, dieser Satz, weil ich ja immer problemlösungsorientiert in eine Diskussion reingehe, Gefühle haben keinen Platz, die Timeline ist wichtig, ja, aber du hast doch dann mir gesagt, ich soll das einkaufen, weiss nicht, also ich stelle dir mal Timelines auf oder kann das dann, habt ihr noch gut im Kopf, wie die Reihenfolge der Dinge waren. Und das ist aber immer nervig, weil für die streitenden, mitstreitenden Personen, weil man die Emotionen außen vor lässt, die ja immer eine Daseinsberechtigung haben, Sternchen, aber zumindest nicht ignoriert werden sollten. Ich finde, es gibt Emotionsräume, in denen kann man Emotionen haben, aber die müssen auch klar abgesteckt werden. Wenn du dich jetzt immer darüber aufregst, dass du, wenn du über eine grüne Ampel läufst und es kommt jemand, ein Fahrradfahrer fährt vor, der hinter dir durch, das ist einfach ein unzulässiger Emotionsraum. Wenn du da Emotionen hast, dann ist es deine Schuld. Und das ist ja auch okay, du kannst ja die Emotion auch haben, aber dann sagt nicht, das ist jetzt wegen dem anderen, sondern dann sagt, und das kenne ich ja auch, ich reg mich ja auch über Dinge auf, die völlig legitim sind und die in Ordnung sind, wo ich einfach weiß, das ist jetzt mein Problem, dass ich diese Emotion habe. Und das ist ja auch völlig okay, aber das kann ich jetzt nicht auf den anderen drücken, sondern ich mag das einfach nicht, wenn das passiert und dann muss ich auch damit leben, aber dann kann man es nicht auf den anderen nehmen. Ich musste neulich abbiegen auf der Autobahn und konnte das fast nicht mehr, weil ich sah schon hinten auf der rechten Spur, wollte mich rechts irgendwann jemand überholen. Ich merke schon, der fährt viel zu schnell auf der rechten Spur, überholt alle, aber er war noch sehr weit weg. Und dann bin ich rechts auf die Abbiegerspur und dann abgefahren. Und an der Ampel fährt der Typ neben mich und macht die Scheibenwischer bis du derfst mit Schugge gehst. Und da habe ich so gedacht, wie gehe ich jetzt damit um, weil er überholt alle rechts und er war noch sehr weit weg, er musste nicht mal bremsen, theoretisch. Irgendwann kommt er die Kurve hinten, da hätte er eh bremsen müssen. Das heißt, er ist vor mir, fährt dann super dicht auf und drückt dann aufs Gaspedal, so wie ich das kenne. So fähr ich nämlich Fahrrad. Immer dieses Stuntman-like, immer so tun, als wäre es gerade super knapp gewesen, dann so abspringen. und dieses Fahrrad, mein Leben hängt am seidenen Faden, ich bremse später, ich gebe noch mal Gas, damit eine Situation knapp wird, um Autofahren zu zeigen, habt ihr einen Vollschaden, willst du mich umbringen? Eigentlich möchte ich jedes Mal, wenn ich Fahrrad fahre, den Satz, willst du mich umbringen, sagen, laut und denken. Weil es ist ein bisschen geil, Autofahrer auflaufen zu lassen. Auf jeden Fall. Aber da, beides Autofahrende, in dieser Situation war es total bescheuert. Er hat den Stefan gemacht, in der Hinsicht, den Stuntfahrer gemacht, ist viel zu lange schnell gefahren. Er hat mich schon sehr weit gesehen. Und dann habe ich neulich, kriege ich jetzt irgendwie die ganze Zeit so Dashcam-Fotos in meine Timelines gespült. Und alle Dashcam-Fahrer fahren genau so. Alle Dashcam-Fahrer, die, das gefühlt läuft das Sendebewusstsein mit, ich will schon gerne jetzt was Geiles zeigen, ich will auf der Dashcam, ich habe eine Dashcam, ich will jetzt, die läuft jetzt nicht ohne Grund, sondern ich will Leuten zeigen, wie bekloppt alle eigentlich fahren. Aber alle Dashcam-Fahrer fahren Stuntmanlike,
bremsen viel zu spät, geben noch mal Gas und dann sind die Kommentare darunter auch, also der
Einsender ist bescheuert, der Einsender ist bescheuert, ja die Leute, die diese Dashcam haben, dann diese Clips
einsenden, die haben oft einfach einen Fahrstil, der geht nicht, klar. Aber da hast du natürlich auch so ein
Sendebewusstsein, wo du sagst, wenn ich schon mal die Dashcam anmache, dann will ich auch Content
generieren, das ist natürlich schwierig, würde ich auch wollen. Ich brauche nur der Finger auf den Aufnahmebutton. Ich weiß nicht, wie es läuft. Geht es automatisch an? Weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube, es ist immer an, ja. Macht man das an? Ich glaube jedenfalls, dass diese Geste macht was in dir. Du fährst dann anders. Ja, ja. Und du willst ja auch der Welt zeigen, wie unge... weil du fühlst dich ja generell ungerecht behandelt von der Welt. Ja, klar. Sonst hättest du ja keine Dashcam. Und dann willst du das aber auch beweisen. Du willst, dass andere Leute sehen, wie schlecht es und wie schlimm es dir geht. Und dann musst du natürlich auch die Szenen manchmal hervorrufen, die das illustrieren. Weil dein abstraktes Gefühl auch konkret dargestellt wird. Ja, dein selektive Wahrnehmen, du willst die Bestätigung dafür haben. Und dann kriegst du den Kommentar, nee, aber da war er rechts vor links. Und du denkst dir, ja, ich weiss schon, aber versteht ihr, ich habe ein abstraktes Gefühl, es geht nicht um das so. Und das ist wahrscheinlich bei dieser mittelalten Frau auch so gewesen, ja, ich weiss, in der konkreten Situation, aber mein Gefühl. Dieser Satz, aber ich habe grünen Wein d, in 20 Situationen richtig recht. Klar war da jetzt nicht rechtens. Spannend, spannend, Auto, Range, Rage. Ja, ich verstehe schon, aber ich kenne auch diesen Gedanken so, ja, ich respektiere dein Gefühl, aber ich finde, du solltest das Gefühl jetzt nicht haben dürfen. Das kenne ich dann auch.
Ich habe kein Problem, deine legitimen Gefühle zu respektieren, aber das ist Bullshit. Aber dann respektierst du die Gefühle nicht. Gefühle sind ja immer irgendwie illegitim und irrational. Dann sehe die Gefühle doch nicht als Argument, sondern als Symptom. Okay, ja. Manchmal ist Augenbrauen hochziehen auch ein völlig legitimer Punkt. Ein Satzende. Warum denkst du, dass jetzt noch was kommt? Hast du überhaupt nicht verstanden, was ich sagen will? Ah, okay, dann hast du mir zugehört. Ach so, ja, nee, nee, klar, verstehe ich schon, verstehe ich schon, verstehe ich schon. Eine spannende soziale Frage möchte ich dir stellen. Die wurde mir zugetragen, ich fand das total klasse. Neulich hatte er einen Freund Geburtstag und er hat mir dann einen Verlauf gezeigt, nämlich eine alte Schulfreundin hat ihm dann geschrieben, hey, alles, alles Gute zum Geburtstag, denkt er nie, sehr nett, weiss ich nicht, alles Liebe, alles Gute, weiss ich auch nicht mehr genau, sagen wir gerade fürs Beispiel, hey, alles, alles Liebe zum Geburtstag, er schreibt, ah, danke, und sie schreibt, gern geschehen. Und er hat mir das gezeigt und hat gesagt, findest du das seltsam und ich habe gesagt hell ja das ist sehr seltsam das ist so das ist sehr seltsam ja und war und dann er weil das eine person die nach jahren das waren alte schulfreunde wieder an ihn denkt den geburtstag im kopf hat an ihn denkt ihm schreibt und bei ihm kam das negativ an, diese ganze Konversion, und bei mir auch.
Ich hab gesagt, was für ein gröner Arschloch, Frau.
Weil du machst,
du reisst alles mit dem Arsch ein,
wenn du gern geschehen schreibst.
Vor allem gern geschehen ist ja ein
Ausdruck, den man nutzt, um eine
Pflicht abzuschliessen.
Du gibst jemandem was oder serviert,
ja, dankeschön, ja, gern geschehen, so, das ist so.
Ich hätte es auch, also ich muss das
tun, aber um diese Höflichkeitsschicht
aufrecht zu erwahren, machen wir
danke, gern geschehen, so. Eigentlich
ruiniert das den kompletten Freiwilligkeitscharakter,
dieses Geburtstagswunsch, und es funktioniert nicht.
Seitdem denke ich unentwegt darüber nach.
In welchen Situationen ist gern geschehen überhaupt
höflich? Weil es ja immer suggeriert,
ich habe gerade was Nettes getan,
aber keine Ursache.
Ja, ja, diese Reaktion
aufs Danke und es ist ja generell die Frage
Eigentlich eine höflich gemeinte Reaktion.
Höflich gemeint, aber natürlich das letzte Wort
an sich zu reißen, ist per se nicht unbedingt
höflich. Das heißt, warum musst du denn
jetzt nochmal was sagen, wenn du sagst, ah, danke,
gern geschehen. So, dann ist der andere wieder in Zugzwang so. Es ist so, das Gespräch zu beenden und die Letzte ist ja natürlich auch ein Machtbeweis, eine Machtposition, wo es schwierig ist. Aber ich sehe jetzt gern geschehen wirklich eher bei so Sachen, wo man sagt, passt schon so, wenn man jemandem Geld leiht und dann gibt man das Geld zurück und dann sagt, danke, so,chehen, so passt schon so, aber es hat was technischeres als jetzt ein Geburtstagswunsch, der ja spontan und unaufgefordert sein soll. Ich glaube, ich sehe gern geschehen eher bei so Pflichten, Zwangshandlungen, wenn jemand ihm was zurückgibt oder wenn man irgendwie. Zwangshandlungen, finde ich nämlich auch, weil so wirkte es, als hätte sie ihm einen Gefallen getan. Als ob das alles, als ob er Arbeit gemacht hat. Als ob er durch seinen, allein den Fakt, dass er auf der Welt ist und Geburtstag hat, ihr so ein bisschen eine Last war. Ja. Sie hat an ihn gedacht, herzlichen Glückwunsch, er sagt Danke, sie sagt Gern geschehen.
So als ob er ihr jetzt verpflichtet wäre, was zu tun.
Nein, er hat Geburtstag, sie freut gern geschehen. So als ob er ihr jetzt verpflichtet wäre, was zu tun. Nein, er hat Geburtstag, sie freut sich, was er auf der Welt ist, dann hast du nicht gern geschehen zu schreiben. Und obwohl so eine Höflichkeit, Floskel, ja im Kern doch ist, hat das alles kaputt gemacht. Und sie liest sich wie das Grösste, ich weiß genau, ich will mit dieser Person und sie hat wohl gemerkt zum Geburtstag gratuliert, aber man liest es und denkt, ich will nicht mit der Befreundheit.
Nee, überhaupt nicht. Nee, das geht nicht. Ich finde, gern geschehen ist auch oft eine Reaktion auf ein übergrosses Danke, wenn man was ganz Besonderes macht für eine Person. So, ich kaufe irgendwas für dich ein und es ist irgendwie ein grosser Umstand und ein grosser Umweg, weil ich weiss, dass du... Ich bring dir nur Haribos mit und du sagst, oh danke, oh das ist genau, was ich heute brauchte, oh vielen Dank, oh vielen Dank, so ein riesen Danke und dann sagst du, nee klar, gern geschehen. Genau, wenn es eine unangemessen hohe ist, oder wenn die Tat auch einfach sehr höflich oder sehr, sehr großzügig ist, wenn du irgendwie weißt, der andere mag irgendwas besonders gerne und du bist in Urlaub und machst was Großes und die Geste ist wirklich groß und toll und dann sagt man man, boah, danke, krass, ja, gern geschehen. Da ist ein Ungleichgewicht. Es ist das Ausgleichen eines Ungleichgewichts. Genau. Manchmal ist das Danke so gross, dass bei dem anderen wieder ein Bedeutungsvakuum entsteht, das man füllen muss mit einem gern geschehen. Aber bei so einem kleinen Moment, wo man zum Geburtstag gratuliert, was man einfach mal machen kann und was auch angemessen ist, ein Gerngeschehen hinten dran zu setzen, als wäre man ein fucking Gott. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Vor allem, man weiss ja, dass die Person an diesem Tag dutzende Geburtstagsgrüsse wegdankt. So, der kriegt wahrscheinlich viele Nachrichten und immer danke, danke, danke, danke, danke. Und dann sich noch rauszuheben und zu sagen, ich schreibe jetzt noch gern Geschehen dazu, zu einem Danke, das ja sehr einfach technisch monoton bei jedem gegeben wird, das finde ich völlig unangenehm.
Das Danke bei Geburtstag ist sogar zu niedrig, da muss man überhaupt nichts ausgleichen mit Gerngeschehen, völlig unangebracht.
Genau.
Völlig unangebracht.
Ja, völlig unangebracht und ich fand, ich muss sehr darüber nachdenken, weil was, wie reagiert man jetzt da drauf?
Es gibt keine gute Antwort mehr aufgesehen.
Er hat überlegt, zu schrieben, keine Ursache zu schreiben.
Und dann bist du natürlich... Und ich fand, ich muss da irgendwo nachdenken, weil was, wie reagiert man jetzt da drauf? Es gibt keine gute Antworten aufgängigend.
Er hat überlegt, zu schreiben, keine Ursache zu schreiben. Und dann bist du natürlich in der Gagalwelt.
Aber das ist auch nicht die richtige Sache. Aber vielleicht sowas wie Danke nochmal.
Sowas wie gerne steht, Danke nochmal.
So nach einem Monat.
Ja genau, danke nochmal.
Hat mir echt viel bedeutet, dass du an mich gedacht hast, so, dass man es dann wirklich nochmal übertreibt. Und dann kommt noch so ein, nee, gar kein Problem. Und dann kann man so unendlich fortsetzen.
Nee, wirklich, nee, es war, ich habe da zuvor ja nicht gedacht.
Überhaupt kein Umstand.
Klar, nee, voll gern geschehen.
Kein, überhaupt kein Umstand, ja.
Boah, das will ich so ein Mindestmaß an Höflichkeit zu geben und dann, gern geschehen. Ich fand's unhöflich, ich fand's arrogant, ich find's da schwingt viel mit. Ganz furchtbar. Das sind wirklich Red Flags, da muss man sofort den Kontakt abbrechen. Aber es ist so eine kleine. Ja, absolut. Aber dadurch, dass dieses soziale Protokoll so felsenfest ist, mit Geburtstagswünschen, ist jedes Abweichen ein Riesending. Ich muss da auch darüber reden, weil es liest sich ja im ersten Moment wie der normalste Verlauf der Welt. Und dann zeigt er mir das aber, weil er da auch darüber nachher das die ganze Zeit, warum er sich jetzt nicht mehr so mag. Und dann lese ich das und es fällt sofort auf. Aber es ist so spannend, weil diesen Verlauf, wenn du den jetzt sehen würdest, als, wenn ich Deutsch als Fremdsprache und du lernst Deutsch, dann hättest du diesen Verlauf drin, würde dir ja nicht auffallen. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Aber so, weil das, wie du sagst, es ist so knallhart abgesteckt, das Protokoll. Ich finde es auch immer komisch, wenn Leute zum Geburtstag gratulieren, sagt man ja als Verb, aber Gratulation zum Geburtstag wäre auch völlig falsch, finde ich so. Du sagst ja alles Gute, alles Liebe, aber Gratuliere zum Geburtstag ist ja völlig falsch, finde ich. Weil Gratuliere ist ja eine Gutierung einer Leistung. Genau. Und Geburtstag ist ja einfach nur ein, ich habe es geschafft, noch ein Jahr zu leben. So, ich bin noch am Leben, gratuliere. In manchen, klar, wenn jetzt jemand viele tödliche Gefahren abwendet, okay, aber wenn jetzt jemand einfach nur vor sich hin lebt, dann ist das keine grosse Leistung. Gratuliere zum Geburtstag. Man kann so viel falsch machen und das ist auch, deswegen habe ich auch Angst, Fremdsprachen zu lernen und zu benutzen, weil man kann so viel falsch machen und so viel kleine Dinge kaputt machen, es ist wirklich. Ja, da ist mir wieder aufgefallen, das Gesellschaftsprotokoll ist sehr, sehr eng getaktet, sehr streng, lässt wenig zu. Ja. Und ja, solche Abweichungen, die machen dann klar, wo Leute das Herz haben. Ich habe jetzt auch wieder ein riesiges Bäckerproblem. Ein Bäckerproblem? Ich habe wieder ein riesiges ... Nein, es ist ... Nein, bitte hör auf, stopp, stopp, stopp, nein, nein, das ist, Essen, Picknick-Essen in den Vordergrund gerückt. Gut, gut. Weltmeisterbrötchen und das war dann immer schon so die ersten fünf Male so kein Problem. Und irgendwann kennt man sich schon und das war auch ein engagierter junger Mitarbeiter, der dann auch schon so wo ich auch schon, nee, überhaupt nicht. gesagt habe, zweitmeistische Berichtung ist, ah ja, so, ah ja, kenn ich schon. So, und jetzt will ich schon nicht mehr hingehen. Es ist leider das Problem von, und das ist genau die Fachhändler, die man will, aber nicht, wenn man selbst, ich als introvertierte Person habe keinen Bock darauf, eine persönliche Beziehung zu den Händlern aufzubauen. Ich will nicht, dass der mich kennt. Ich will nicht, dass der weiss, was ich bin, was ich esse, weil das esse ich ja in meinem Körper drin und dann wird das verdaut und all das, ich will nicht, das ist einfach eine Transaktion. Und ich zahle auch immer mit Karte. Und das war dann auch so ein Element, was dann immer wieder bei dann, und dann meinte er, ah, mit Karte. Ja, mit Karte Karte so und es hat sich immer mehr zu einem Automatismus bewegt, aber dann irgendwann kommt schon so ein na heute wieder zwei Weltmeisterbrötchen es gibt aber dann auch andere Tage, wo ich kein Weltmeisterbrötchen nehme, sondern so helle Buhls, die auch immer so furchtbar beschrieben sind, helle Buhl, dunkle Buhls, ich glaube es istisches oder irgendwie so ein Bullshit. Aber irgendwie keine, es ist einfach nervig, vielleicht ist auch was Hamburgerisches. Buhl. B-O-U-L-E, Buhl. Und dann ist ja helle, helle das hier, dieses da, jenes Ding so. Und es ist auch der Unterschied zwischen Weltmeisterbrötchen und Buhl. Ist auch so, finde ich ganz unangenehm. Aber da kommt mir alles hoch. Ist wirklich richtig unangenehm. Also Handbrötchen, Buhl rustig. Ja, Buhl rustig, helle Buhl und einfach Bullshit so. Weil es gibt manchmal und dann sag ich mal. Buhl rustig, niemals. Ja, Buhl rustig. Es sieht fantastisch aus. Es ist auch gut, es ist auch gut. Niemals könnte ich mir auch was Herz bringen, das zu essen, ich würde drauf zeigen, aber müssen wir vielleicht noch über die, ja.
Ja, weil das Wettmeisterbrötchen, finde ich, gibt schon relativ viel vor, das esse ich gerne mit Schinken oder Hummus oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Woher kommt der Name, damals von WM 2006?
Ja, ich glaube, als wir es gewonnen haben, hat Götze, dass dann, dürfte Götze sich selber ein Brot designen und das ist das beste Brot der Welt. Was kann dieser Mann eigentlich nicht? Und deswegen hole ich mir das gerne, aber manchmal gibt es Tage, da gehe ich zum Hähnchenwagen. Ja, so, wenn ich zum Hähnchen war. Und ich esse gern zum Hähnchen auch mal eine Buhl. So, und dann hole ich mir an den Tagen Buhl. Aber das ist relativ ungleichmässig und schwer vorherzusagen, wann diese Tage sind, vor allem für den äusseren Betrachter. Aber das gefällt mir, weil du bist ja in so einer, also du bist on the verge of disaster mit dem Herrn. Genau. Weil du bist wirklich so vier, fünf Besucher entfernt, dass du da nicht mehr hingehen kannst. Weil, ich male nämlich das Horrorszenario aus, du gehst hin, er sagt, ah, zwei Weltmeisterbrötchen mit Karte und du sagst, okay, ich möchte nicht mehr hier hingehen, niemals, ich hasse alles, ich hasse mein Leben und mich. Da bist du ja wirklich so vier Besuche von entfernt. Und was du schon richtig machst ist, und das müsst ihr machen, Prinzip of Chaos. genau weil wenn du wenn wenn sozusagen du vorhersehbar wirst dann bildet sich plötzlich
so eine freundschaft und so eine Scheinfreundschaft und die ist furchtbar, da musst du gehen. Wenn du aber Chaosprinzip anwendest und dann irgendwann noch sagst, okay, jetzt hätte ich gern 20 Croissants, haha, okay, I'm this guy now und ich hätte gern einen Kaffee, aber ohne Milch, so dann, dann wirst du so Curveballs hin und das ist glaube ich sehr gut, weil dann kann er gar nicht diese Beziehung aufbauen. Und genau so war es dann auch ein paar Mal, dass ich dann so hingegangen bin und er dann so, äh, ich kann jetzt schon mitreden und ich so, eine Buhl bitte. Und das war dann so, okay, so. Und das ist auch unangenehm. Wir sind noch nirgends. Genau, es ist auch unangenehm, dass es so rausgestellt wird, dass es so besonders ist. Weil seinen Blick sagt dann, ich dachte, wir wären Freunde. Ja, und dann, genau, er war dann sehr, sehr gebrochen und hat dann, ja gut, dann schmeiße ich einfach alle Weltmeisterbrötchen weg, oder wie, okay, dann können die alle in Müll, dann können die alle in Müll! Und das war der Punkt, wo ich gemerkt habe, Uli, kommst du mal kurz nach hinten, bitte, warum willst du jetzt alle Weltmeister? Ja, wenn er sie nicht haben will, dann kann ich die Weltmeister helfen. Wieso? Da habe ich schon gemerkt, oh, es geht in eine komische Richtung. Und dann gab es einen schicksalhaften Tag, als ich am Bäcker stand und vor mir war noch eine junge Mutter mit Kind. Und dann dauert das ja oft länger so mit, ah, was willst du hin und da da und ich habe schon geschielt und habe gesehen, es gibt nur noch zwei Weltmeisterbrötchen.
An dem Tag kein Huhn im Rucksack, war das eigentlich meine geplante Mahlzeit.
Also schaue ich drauf und denke, ah fuck, nimmt die, will die das haben, so es sind nicht mehr so wahnsinnig viele Brötchen da, was ist, wenn sie jetzt eins nimmt, nehme ich dann das noch mit was anderem und dann denke ich so nach und gucke da so hin und plötzlich sehe ich die Hand und beide Weltmeisterbrötchen werden gegriffen und ich denke mir, fuck, scheiße, jetzt sind sie weg. Und dann schaue ich hoch und sehe, dass der die einpackt und vor mich hin liegt. Nein! Boah, ich ... Ich hasse das.
Es ist so cringe, ich hasse das.
Es ist so cringe, es ist so cringe. Und der hat an der aktuellen Kundin vorbei, ohne meinen Wunsch, die Weltmesser wurden automatisch genommen und mir gegeben. Und das war der Punkt, wo ich sagte, es war eine schöne Reise, aber ich werde diesen Laden nie wieder betreten. Hier ist Schluss. War er der einzige Bäckermeister oder Bäckangestellte? Es gibt da verschiedenes Personal. Er war nicht in der Bedienung mit der Frau Fordi. Doch, doch, doch, das schon, das schon, an dem Tag schon. Und es war wirklich so so und der einfach sieht mich und nimmt an am aktuellen kunden vorbei zwei im ersten pack sie ein karte und ich habe gezahlt vor der anderen dame war bin gegangen noch bevor die transaktion mit der mutter vor mir beendet wurde ich war wurde quasi vorgelassen schnürt sich mir alles ab. Wer war die Mail? Gleich, machen wir gleich. Es schnürt sich alles zusammen. Oh mein Gott, das ist so unangenehm. Oh, es ist so unangenehm. Es ist so unangenehm. Und vor allem, ich dachte mir so, was ... Oh, ist auch dieses, ich mach's kurz mit ihm schon mal, wir kennen uns, sind Stammkunde hier. Oh, das ist so furchtbar. Und eigentlich ist es ja eine coole, nette Geste und ich war schneller fertig und eigentlich dran und alles, was man sich ja von so einer Serviceinteraktion wünscht, aber es ist zu viel. Oh, es ist so schrecklich, es ist so, so, so schlimm. Ich weiß gar nicht, was das alles so, also, allein dass diese Mutter dann da mit dem Kind redet wahrscheinlich und sagt, möchtest du noch ein Schokokroissant? Ja. Und er dann so, ich mach schon mal hier mit meinem Kumpel, hm, mein Weltmeisterkumpel. Mein kleiner Weltmeister. Mein kleiner Weltmeister. Du bist der Weltmeister. Und das ist jetzt tatsächlich schon ein paar Mal vorgekommen, dass er unkommentiert, ungefragt direkt sein Weltmeisterbrötchen nimmt und mir gibt. Und es hat immer gepasst. Meine Schicksalsfrage ist natürlich jetzt, kann ich jetzt überhaupt noch jemals zum Händchenstand gehen mit dem Wissen, dass ich ja unmöglich, und das ist jetzt mein Problem, ich kann ja unmöglich das ablehnen. Es gibt für mich in meinem sozialen Interaktionshandbuch kein Kapitel für, er gibt mir die Tüte und ich sag, nee, ich will eigentlich eine Buhl. Und was macht der dann, tut er die wieder zurück? Aber du hast, aber du hast, aber du hast, das kannst du niemals, niemals machen. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das gibt's nicht.
Aber was ist, wenn du mehr Brötchen willst?
Ich hab jetzt keine andere Bestellung mehr als Zerwettmesser. Ich kann nichts anderes mehr nehmen. Aber wenn irgendwer da draußen im Service arbeitet mit Menschen, das darf doch nicht im Regelbuch stehen. Da muss doch gross stehen, gibt Leuten einen Handlungsspielraum. Du kannst doch nicht Leuten, es kann auch sein sein, dass du liebst Weltmeisterbröhrchen, du brauchst mal drei. Ja, ja. Du hast einen Kumpel zu Besuch, ihr braucht drei. Absolut. Ihr macht ein Weltmeisterbröhrchen abends mit vier, fünf sage und schreibe acht Weltmeisterbröhrchen. Und er gibt dir immer diese zwei. Er kann es nicht sagen, ich hink dir acht. Nee, es geht nicht. Und er sagt, ja, okay. Ja, dann nimmt er die. Ja, dann nimmt alle, dann wirft alle auf mich. er nimmt den ganzen korb weltweiten und gibt mir alle aber ich freue mich gerade genau dieses schmeißt einfach dieses dieses gepackt vorgepackte tüte in den müll und machte dann noch eine andere mit acht und sagt ja es ist so weil wir hatten das thema ja auch mit dem mit dem backwaren backwaren diebstahl wo ich jaüte geklaut habe, wo ich ja auch gesagt habe, wenn die das mal in die Tüte reintun, werden die das dann nicht wieder irgendwie rausnehmen, sondern die werfen das weg. Und hier denke ich mir wirklich, was passiert, wenn ich jetzt wirklich sage, ich hätte stattdessen gerne eine Bull. Also ich glaube, bei ihm ist er Service. Ja, andere Theorie habe ich jetzt gleich noch, da seit er dich kennt, aber das können wir hinten anstellen.
Die erste Theorie wäre, Aria geht ganz anders, als man denkt, wir cringen uns jetzt zusammen, weil wir den enttäuschten Mann vor uns sehen. Ja, ja. Die Wahrheit wird wahrscheinlich sein, der sagt, oh okay, war ich vorschnell, nimmt sie raus, packt sie eine grössere Tüte oder ähm, aber dieses, er hat sich schon mal angefasst und gibt die dir, also was anderes zu nehmen ist unmöglich. Ja. Mehr Weltmeisterbrötchen zu glaube ich dinge noch eine bulrustik obendrauf diese scheinchen tag rustik also alles daran ist furchtbar das ist so spannend für mich weil ich habe so oft diese beziehung zu ja service orientierten jobshändlern die es gut. Aber ich kann nicht mehr hingehen, weil es die normale Kunden-HändlerInnen-Perspektive überschreitet irgendwann. Und deswegen war ich immer so geil, weil ich hatte immer einen Bäcker bei mir in der Nähe, bin da jeden Morgen hin, bis irgendwann das Grinsen schon gross wurde, wenn ich reinkam und ah, guten Morgen, wo man schon merkt, so okay, ich bin angezählt. Und dann mich, da hast du mich gegengesprochen, du hast zu oft zwei Weltmeisterbüttchen geholt. Ja, das kann schon sein. Ich hab, wie gesagt, die Bull war ab und zu mit dabei, weswegen ich dachte, und es gab ja auch manchmal so Tage, wo es einfach keine Weltmeisterbüttchen mehr gab und ich dann so zwei Weltmeisterbüttchen und er so, naja, gibt's leider nicht mehr und dann so, äh, was nehme ich ich stattdessen, das war dann so ein Ding, wo das irgendwie, aber es hat einfach nicht. Ich habe immer ein belegtes Gauterbrötchen genommen und irgendwann war die Rezeptur eine andere. Da war nämlich dann Remoulade drauf und keine Butter mehr. Und da habe ich gemerkt, ah okay, ich bin wieder fein, also eigentlich, ja, ich kriege dann dieses Remouladenbrötchen, hasse ich, hasse ich, habe ein scheiss Essen, aber ich war so erleichtert darüber, dass ich nichts zähle. Ah, okay, dass er nicht wegen dir das bewahrt, sondern okay. Ich bin weiterhin der grauanonyme, austauschbare Kunde. Also du denkst dir, dass jetzt da von ganz oben, von der Zentrale, dann kam, ja, jetzt auf die Gauderbrötchen kommt Remoulade und er sagt, nein, das kann ich nicht machen. Es gibt diesen einen jungen Mann, der immer sehr müde und schläfrig hier reinkommt, kurz davor ist vorm Einschlafen, der will ein Gauderbrötchen und der soll sein Gauderbrötchen mit Butter bekommen. Aber das war es nicht. Genau das war es nicht, weil das ist super unangenehm. Dann liegt auf mir so eine Last. Wer bin ich denn für andere zu sprechen? Lord Kamps sagt Remoulade und er sagt, gut, ich führe willenlos Remoulade aus. Und deswegen lobe ich mir meinen Kamps. Schmecken die Brötchen da besser? Nein, aber es ist eine anonyme, kalte Kundeninteraktion. Genau, richtig. Es ist dieser Riesenkonzern und dann ändert die Rezeptur. Mag ich jetzt nicht mehr, ist mir scheißegal, ich zähle nichts. Genau, ich will nicht zählen. Serviceinteraktion ist ja so toll, weil ich nichts machen muss. Ja, weil du introvertiert bist. Weil ich drücke einfach auf Knöpfe im Automaten und es geht nicht um mich. Ich will nicht, dass es um mich geht. Ja, wir wollen keine Aufmerksamkeit. Genau, ich will nicht, ich will, dass ich zähle. Ich bin Kunde Nummer 187 und sonst nichts. Ich will einfach da auf die Knöpfe drücken. Und bei mir ist es jetzt wirklich so, dass ich da erstens nicht mehr gerne hingehe und zweitens, wenn ich was anderes als zwei Weltmeisterbrötchen will, gehe ich zu einem anderen Bäcker. Weil ich kann, es geht einfach, wenn ich sehe, der arbeitet, kann ich da nicht hingehen, es geht einfach nicht mehr. Und ich kann Hähnchen auch nicht mit Weltmeisterbrötchen essen, das ist auch keine Option. Weil der junge Herr, es ist so spannend, weil der junge Herr ist ja im Prinzip das, was alle, wenn du einstellst für deine Bäckerei, willst du ja so einen Mann. Absolut, der ist ein super Typ. Du willst ja einen jungen, engagierten, aufmerksamen Kerl, aber eigentlich willst du den nicht, weil der ist geschäftsschädigend. Also ironischerweise sind aufmerksame, clevere, wache Leute, die sich mit gutem Gedächtnis merken können, was wer will, sind fucking geschäftsschädigend für Leute wie uns, weil wir da nicht mehr hängen gehen können. Ich glaube, tatsächlich bei älteren Herrschaften, die Oma, die über Grün geht, von dir angehubt wird und fast überfahren wird, die hat da glaube ich eine gute Zeit. Die fühlt sich dann da gesehen und aufgehoben. Oder meine Mutter zum Beispiel würde hingehen und wenn da jemand sagt, ah wollen Sie das haben, dann würde sie sich freuen. Dann fühlt sie sich gesehen und denkt, ah cool, ich mache einen Unterschied. Wir hingegen wollen das nicht. Und deswegen ist die Frage, wenn ihr einstellt für euer Bäckerei-Fachgeschäft. Es braucht eigentlich immer zwei Leute an der Schicht, den für die Introvertierten und den für die Extrovertierten. Und für die Introvertierten muss so ein ganz kühler, unaufmerksamer Typ sein, der einfach abarbeitet wie ein Roboter. Und dann willst du so einen Labersack für die Extrovertierten. Und für die Infrovertierten muss so ein ganz kühler, unaufmerksamer Typ sein, der ist einfach abarbeitet wie ein Roboter. Und dann willst du so einen Labersack für die Extrovertierten, so, ah, Frau Müller, ach schön, ach jetzt wieder den Kürbiskern, ach toll, ist ihr Sohn wieder da? Ja, genau wie diese Videos, die gerade rumgehen von diesem Kellner, der auf dieser heißen Platte Leute bedient. So dieses Event-Ding, ja. So ein Event-Kochen. Ja. Horror für mich. Ja,recklich. Wen hättest du lieber, eine schlecht gelaunte Arschloch-Mitarbeiterin oder einen gut gelaunten jungen Herrn, dem die Sonne im Gesicht steht. Immer Arschloch. Ich will Arschloch, zack, Interaktion, beendet, fertig. Das ist so. Und es ist immer so, auch wenn ich mit Leuten essen bin oder so und die sagen, das Service hier ist echt schlecht, und ich denke mir, was, so perfekt, einfach so wirklich, einfach kaltes Abarbeiten, fertig und durch, ich mag das. Für mich ist ja sowieso manchmal so, sieht man so Videos aus Japan, wo man dann so diese automatisierten Rahmenbars hat oder so, wo du wirklich nur so in so einer Box drin sitzt und dann gibst du das an und dann geht nur eine Klappe auf und das Essen kommt raus, keine Interaktion, das ist absolut perfekt und Service sollte sich daran orientieren, wie schaffe ich es, ein Erlebnis möglichst nah an dieser Japan-Box zu machen, dass am besten auch man gar nicht sich in die Augen schaut jemals und so, aber das ist das Ding und das ist auch schwer an Service, du musst natürlich gucken, was willst du haben. Nee, die wahre Kunstst ist nämlich empathisch zu erkennen was braucht man
ja das ist schwer und eigentlich brauchst du den jungen mann der aber dann noch die empathie hat zu checken das genau nicht was du willst das ist das friseur dilemma glaube ich auch so weil wenn ich immer ich muss jetzt gucken ob ich in hamburg neuen friseur suche so weil in köln habe ich meinen so da ist alles safe so kein wort gesprochen einfach nichts stille ich mache die augen zu stille ertragen und fertig und sowas in hamburg auch und dann ist halt immer die frage so hoffentlich check die person dass ich nicht reden will und das ist immer die frage und denkst ja hoffentlich bist du empathisch oder taxifahrer sowas und da musst du immer gucken komme ich an jemanden der empathisch genug ist dass er dass er checkt dass ich nicht reden will bei mir ist es so ich habe dann zu zu meiner friseurin irgendwann so eine freundschaft aufgebaut einfach weil ich das auch nicht aushalte nicht zu reden und dann ist es so inzwischen dann dann hat man sich alles erzählt und dann ist es wieder angenehm weil es ist nämlich du musst dich so ein es ist so eine gaussche glocke ja ja weil wenn man sich nicht kennt und dann ist dieser dieser weirdes small Smalltalk ist dann total bescheuert, den, den willst du ja umgehen, indem du einfach die Stille aushältst, das wäre mir dann auch lieber und dann irgendwann durch knallhartes Oversharen beiderseits hat sich dann so eine Freundschaft entwickelt und das ist dann auch wieder gut und deswegen habe ich tatsächlich nur beides. Ich habe bei, bei, bei Händlern, Fachhändlern oder DienstleisterInnen in meinem Leben diese beiden Extreme.
Es bildet sich fast eine Freundschaft, wo man die Handynummer hat und man geht hin und kauft was oder knallharte Anonymität. Dazwischen ist nämlich dein Kerl und das könnte ich gar nicht aushalten. Ich komme da jetzt echt nicht mehr raus. Ich gucke immer, wer arbeitet jetzt immer. So, ich gehe dann immer erst in den Super schaue währenddessen kurz, wer arbeitet und wenn der da arbeitet, dann muss ich dem Blick einfach ausweichen. Ich habe jetzt eine andere Situation erlebt und da habe ich, glaube ich, meinen Gegenteil, also das, was Wario zu Mario ist, ist dieser Beffern zu Stefan. Also ich habe wirklich mein absolutes Gegenteil entdeckt, weil, und es geht auch um eine, ja, Händlersituation, denn ich, du hast gerade angesprochen, Japan, ich bin gerade irgendwie so japanisches Interior, ich mag, ich finde Bonsai-Bäume gerade spannend und ich glaube, ist das wieder nur eine Phase, also ich glaube, da könnte eine Phase kommen. Phase Bonsai, okay, interessant, finde ich gut. Hat was Ruhiges, Beruhigendes. Du quälst halt Pflanzen einfach.
Zu mir finden.
Du musst die halt so hart verstümmeln, dass die aus Angst kleine Blätter bauen. Kleine Bäume werden. Weil die einfach so komplett verstümmelt werden. Das ist ja die Idee, du musst die so lange schlecht machen und klein machen, dass es kleine Bäume bleiben. Also das ist wichtig, das Selbstbewusstsein klein halten. Du musst die ja runtermachen, ja. Das Selbstbewusstsein, das steht auch immer drauf in diesen Broschüren, in dieser ruhigen Zen-Musik steht dann da, du musst die Bäume so schlecht machen, dass sie kein Selbstbewusstsein entwickeln und von sich aus in diesen kleinen Töpfen bleiben wollen. Der Baum will gebrochen werden. Genau. Die Blätter sind naturgemäss zu gross. Sag, du bist schlecht, du bist eine scheiss Unke. Du bist nichts wert. Siehst du die Unke da vorm Haus? Riesig, oder? Das könntest du niemals sein. Siehst du, wie stark und mächtig sie sind? Das rückt dir deine mickrigen kleinen Wurzelchen an. Du dummer, dummer Baum. Der, die Unke da draußen, würde sich niemals einpflanzen lassen, kleinen Topf. Die hat noch Stolz. Aber du. Die hat Ehrgeiz. Du nicht. Du nicht. Du bist ein kleiner Bonsai, du hast dich gefangen lassen. Du bist ein kleiner Setzling, mehr nicht. Da währenddessen dann so Gongschläge und so Teelzeremonien und das riecht gut. Irgendwie habe ich Spaß an dieser Bonsai-Kultur und auch dieses, ja was es das macht, den zu pflegen, zu gießen, dieses feuchte, ja ja. Pflegen, ja. So, also dann habe ich entdeckt, in meiner Nähe gab es so einen Laden. Und mit Laden meine ich so einen privaten Mann, der die verkauft. Und dann bin ich da hingelatscht und der war wirklich mein absolutes Gegenteil. Also du kommst da hin und es war nicht ein Shop, so mit einem Laden, wo du reingehst, sondern es war so sein Wintergarten-mäßig, so ein Hinterhof, lag da auch so Schrott rum und dann war da so ein Wohnwagen, wo die Reifen ab waren und alles war so merkwürdig und dann stand da so ein paar Bonsai-Bäume rum. Dann habe ich dem das so gesagt, was ich gerne, der war sehr nett, aber ich habe ihm gesagt, dass ich gerne so ein für, wenn man ein Wohnzimmer so ein Bonsai braucht. Und es stand auch Indoor-Bonsais auf der Website. Und dann hat er gesagt, ja, geh schon mal rein, habe ich nicht so viel da. Ich so, ja, ist kein Problem. Komm rein und dann hat er noch mit seinem anderen Kunden gesprochen und dann kam er wieder und hat gesagt, ja, folgendes, also Indoor-Bäume macht ja keinen Sinn, Bäume wachsen ja nicht drinnen. Bäume wollen draußen sein. Indoor-Bäume gibt's nicht, die gehen ein, die wollen nicht drinnen sein. Da habe ich so mich umgeguckt und überall waren halt Bäume, kleine Minibäume, gefangen in kleinen Töpfen, wo ich dachte, das wirkt ja auch schon unnatürlich. Mit keinem Selbstlossein, Kopf hängen, gebrochen. Und dann hat er mich so lange unterrichtet darüber, dass mein Grundinteresse schon so falsch ist, dass ich dann am Ende da gegangen bin, geknickt. Dann wollte ich da noch so Scheinfragen gestellt wie, ja wie läuft das denn, diese Pflege, und er hat gesagt, er muss halt pflegen, muss halt formen. Und also, und da habe ich gesagt, ah, der Mann ist halt mein absoluter, mein absolutes Gegenteil, ist meine Antithese. Ich bin Phasentyp.
Ja, und der verachtet diese Hipsterphasen, die so kurz mal schnell irgendwie sein Lebenswerk irgendwie auch machen wollen. Er hat ein Mono-Interesse, so sehr, dass er über dieses Mono-Mini-Mikro-Interesse einen Laden baut. Und das ist sein Leben.
Und das zieht er durch.
Und da gibt es keine Kompromisse,
da gibt es keine, ich stelle mir mal
einen Bonsai ins Wohnzimmer, sondern
es ist geballtes Wissen und tiefen Wissen.
Meins ist ja wirklich
diese oberflächliche, diese Begeisterungsfähigkeit,
dieses mal reingucken in Hobbys,
dieses mal,
ich weiß nicht, mal fühlen.
Und das war so mein absolutes Gegenteil.
Aber ich mag diese Menschen
. Dieses Mal reingucken in Hobbys, dieses Mal, ich weiß nicht, mal fühlen. Und das war so mein absolutes Gegenteil. Aber ich mag diese Menschen überhaupt nicht. Ja, das sind so Gatekeeper, die einfach das Tor zuhalten. Das sind Leute mit Shops und Websites, die die Shops bewerben, wo drinsteht, wir haben auch Indoor-Bäume.
Als Falle, ja.
Ja, und dann habe ich auch gesagt, ich wurde in eine Falle gelockt. Dann gehst du da hin und fragst du noch Indoor-Bäume und er sagt, Indoor-Bondal-Bäume? Die gibt sich raus! Aber da stand 20 Euro pro Stück. 20? Und dann gibt er dir so ein Blatt,
gibt er dir, das ist 20 Euro wert.
Ja genau, und du bist auch reingeholt,
um gemobbt zu werden.
Horror.
Genau so ist es, er hat selber das Beispiel angeführt,
du gehst ja auch nicht in den Gitarrenladen
und kaufst dir eine Gitarre,
wenn du nicht Gitarre spielen kannst,
hat er gesagt.
Und genau diese Art Gitarrenverkäufer kennt man ja auch. Damals, als ich angefangen habe, Gitarre zu spielen, wollte ich mir eine schöne Gitarre kaufen. Da hat mir mein Vater wirklich so, der hat das Hobby unterstützen wollen und hat so gesagt, ey, du kannst eine schöne Gitarre kaufen, schenkst dir zum Geburtstag, kannst dir eine Gitarre im Laden kaufen. Und das Budget, was er mir gegeben hat, war höher als mein Skill-Level. Aber ich fand das toll. Ich finde das immer noch super und auch rückblickend in der Rückschau. Ich als Vater wäre genauso. Wenn ein Kind Interesse an etwas hat, mit grossen, wässrigen, im Sinne von Freude, nicht im Sinne von Wein, müden Augen. Mit grossen, wässrigen Augen. Ich meine, dein Vater war überrascht, dass du überhaupt mal wach bist. Er dachte, okay, wenn es die Musik ist, die ihn wach hält, ja, gerne. Es ist eh ein sehr günstiges Kind, muss man sagen. Wir gehen nie in den Zoo, nie in den Schwimmbad, wir brauchen nie Wildpark, nie Tierpark. Wir brauchen nur ein Bett. Also, genau. Und dann hat er mir Geld gegeben und dann war ich in diesem Laden und dann war halt da so ein Gatekeependes Arschloch, wie ich sie nenne, und wollte mir halt nur die billigste Billow-Gitarre verkaufen, weil ich ja noch nichts kann. Und mein Gegenargument da, weil ich glaube, diesen Leuten sind die Sachen, die sie verkaufen, liegen denen sehr am Herzen. Es sind ja diese sehr, muss man auch sagen, nachhaltigen, tollen, kleinen Läden, lokalen Läden, die man ja unterstützen sollte. Ich habe da so ein bisschen so einen Hass gegen, weil die verkau... Den ist diese Scheiss-Gitarre für 200... Keine Ahnung, diese Akustik-Gitarre, die, ich weiß nicht, Emanuel Garzon noch handgeklöppelt hat bei sich in Valencia, die will er nicht er nicht verkaufen. Weil er die, die will er nicht verkaufen, der es verdient hat, der es sich erarbeitet hat. Ich kriege dann die dusselige Yamaha-Gitarre für 30 Euro. Die ist aber schlecht verarbeitet, klingt scheisse und vermutlich lege ich das irgendwann weg und habe keinen Bock mehr auf das Hobby, ja vielleicht auch, weil die Gitarre scheisse ist. Das sind gatekeepende Arschlöcher für mich. Wenn ein Kind, ich hätte gerne einen Laden, also erstmal will ich mal, habe ich ja auch ein, weiss ich nicht, kaufmännisches Interesse, Leuten was zu verkaufen, das haben die ja nicht. da verstehe ich das habe ich ein fragezeichen bei mir so um die zu verstehen und dann ist es
aber auch so dieses wenn leute mit begeisterungsfähigkeit bei mir in den Laden kommen, verkaufe ich denen alles. Weil die könnten ja die neue, die neue Koryphäe auf dem Gebiet werden. Auf jeden Fall, klar. Und jetzt habe ich komischerweise dadurch so ein Interesse, mir so einen krassen Bonsai zu kaufen und gegen den auf so Bonsai-Show-Wettbewerben zu gewinnen. Auf der großen Bonsai-Messe bist du dann auch da und hast mehr Leute an deinem Stand als er. Und vielleicht ist das ja der eigentliche Trick dieser Leute, dass sie deinen Ehrgeiz wecken, dadurch, dass sie dir Hürden geben und du dann über sie hinaus wachsen willst. Oder halt unter sie wachsen. Ich weiß nicht, wie bei Bonsai, wie man das regelt. Ist der Beste der Kleinste? Ich weiß es nicht genau. weiss niemand genau. Und dann war ich an irgendeinem Punkt plötzlich mit
ihm, dass er mir,
habe ich schon gemerkt, es gab so zwei,
drei Bonsai-Bäume, die er mit mir verkauft hätte.
Ganz kleine
und so anfängerfreundliche.
Noch sehr selbstbewusst.
Hässliche, muss ich sagen.
Da waren superschöne Bonsai-Bäume.
Mit so ganz kleinen Blättern, richtig geil
so wie so große Bäume, urig gewachsene rustikale Bäume im Minimastab, superschick. Ne, das war gar nicht, das hätte ich nicht kaufen können. Und das war nicht so faszinierend und das habe ich genau gemerkt, das ist mein Gegenteil. Du, ich freue mich und ich glaube alle hören dann auch auf die zwei Wochen, die wir jetzt mit Bonsai-Stefan verbringen dürfen, bis der Bonsai dann im Müll landet. Aber es gibt tatsächlich echte Innovationen, auch im botanischen Bereich tatsächlich, habe ich jetzt festgestellt. Und zwar irgendwie, keine Ahnung, wir sind ja eine verlorene Generation, die sich damit abgefunden hat, dass es nicht besser wird. Und dass eigentlich nichts vorangeht. Und deswegen bin ich immer wieder schockiert, wenn es punktuell dann doch vorangeht. An Punkten, wo ich es nicht erwartet hätte. Versteckte Innovationen. Wir haben ja darüber gesprochen, die Süssigkeitenindustrie steckt fest, lange im Sumpf der Gleichartigkeit irgendwie. Dann der Knoppersriegel, dann KitKat mit Karamell, so immer das Gleiche, nur so ein bisschen leicht anders. Wo ist die echte Innovation? Und jetzt habe ich eine Innovation gefunden, wo ich sie nicht erwartet hätte, und zwar beim Knoblauch. Und ich dachte eigentlich… Ich bin der grösste Knoblauch-Fan. Ich dachte eigentlich, Knoblauch ist durch. Ich dachte, wir haben es so. Das ist perfekt. Wir sind angekommen. Aber ich hatte letzte Woche einen Knoblauch in der Hand, wo ich mir dachte, holy shit, das geht? Und zwar Knoblauch, wir alle stellen uns ja Knoblauch vor als Knolle, bestehend aus Zehen.
Und dann die Zehen musst du dann einzeln.
Und die Zehen bestehen aus Frivolen.
So, und dann musst du ja die Knolle, und dann guckst du die Zehen einzeln, und dann musst du die auffriemeln.
Und ich hatte eine Knolle in der Hand, wo die gesamte Knolle Zehe war.
Ein Zehe?
Eine Zehe pro Knolle.
Eine Riesenzähe? Eine Riesenzen zehe so gross wie eine knolle wo man so reinbeissen kann wie so ein apfel ein riesen ding es gab nicht diese Unterteilungen nicht diese einzelnen dinger die man abfummeln muss mit diesen mit dieser haut die man dann kommt eine zehe aber die hatte die haut die hatte eine klassische knollenhaut woher wussteest du das dann? Ich habe sie geöffnet und habe gesehen, ich habe sie geöffnet, ich habe sie auch verzerrt. Ich habe sie geöffnet und dachte mir, ich habe mich schon eingestellt auf die vielen Zehen, die jetzt auf mich zukommen. Nein, eine Knolle, eine Zehe. War das ein Wachstumsfehler? Nein, die ganze Packung war so, die ganze Packung war so, alle waren so, aus China, anscheinend die neueste Innovation der Knoblauchwelt. Und ich dachte mir, ich war wirklich kurz sprachlos, weil ich mir dachte, das geht? Also man kann das noch, also weil Knoblauch, ich liebe Knoblauch, aber es ist immer sau nervig mit diesen einzelnen Zehen und irgendwie geht es anders. Aber du kannst ja kaum damit kochen, weil alle Rezepte auf Zehen als grösste Wahrschaften. Das ist ein Problem, das ist ein Problem. Und ich habe ja auch dann so eine Knoblauchpresse, muss ich teilen, weil es war zu gross für die Knoblauchpresse. Fantastisch, wir brauchen neue Knoblauchpressen, die gross genug sind um die ganze Knoblauch, war fantastisch. Und ich war wirklich, ich dachte, ich konnte mich den ganzen Tag nicht zur Ruhe kommen. Da dachte er so, müssen wir uns denn eigentlich mit Mandarinen abgeben, mit diesen einzelnen Stücken, müssen wir uns abgeben. Äpfel haben immer noch Kerne, wo ist denn da? Können wir uns nicht so eine riesige Weintraube oder so statt diesen kleinen, also was ist denn alles möglich, weil es gab zu meinen Lebzeiten keine einzige Obst und Gemüse Revolution, nichts. Das ist das erste Mal in meinem gesamten Leben, dass ich so eine, weil man kennt ja so Bilder von alten Bananen, die dann irgendwie total furchtbar aussahen. Die noch gerade waren. Die noch gerade waren und dann nach langem, langem Züchten konnte sie verändert werden. Und das war das erste Mal, dass ich wirklich gesagt habe, holy shit. Naja, Trauben, Weintrauben ohne Kerne. Sind die zu unseren Lebzeiten entstanden? Nein, das meine ich nicht zu unseren Lebzeiten, aber ich glaube, unsere Elterngeneration hat das irgendwann erlebt als Innovation. Du meinst, es gibt eine Innovation pro Generation und unsere Generation Innovation ist die volle Zehe. Weil ich liebe Knoblauch, ich finde das eines der besten Nahrungsmittel der Welt. Eigentlich ein Ballen, es ist ein Fussballen. Es ist eigentlich keine kleinen Zehen mehr, sondern einfach ein Fuss. Also einfach ein Fuss, was du hast. Ja, wie sind die Zwiebel. Es ist fantastisch. Und seitdem bin ich ein bisschen im Innovationsmodus und denke mir, was können wir eigentlich noch ändern, weil man nimmt ja die Welt wahr als unveränderbar und fest und so hat es es zu sein granate aber es gibt noch viele aber ein granat einfach eine granade ein riesen ding jetzt bin ich natürlich kein botaniker ich habe ich kann jetzt hier behaupten was ich will aber ich bin kein botaniker ich da ich bin dann wieder in den supermarkt zurückgegangen wo mein innovationsgarten liegt und dachte und dachte mir folgendes, pass auf, es gibt für mich oft die Situation, Supermarkt plus Bäcker gemeinsam. Bäcker, zwei Weltmeistermöglichkeiten haben wir alles geklärt, alles furchtbar.
Aber ich stehe an der Supermarktkasse und denke mir, warum kann ich jetzt nicht zum Bäcker? Warum kann ich nicht in der Zeit, in der ich an der Kasse stehe, zum Bäcker gehen? Weil niemand ist am Bäcker. Kann ich nicht, also dann habe ich mir überlegt, kann man nicht einfach sein, kann man nicht so eine Art Handtuch in die Schlange legen, das ist den Platz reserviert, währenddessen gehe ich zum Bäcker, kaufe da mein Brötchen, gehe zurück, oder eine App, du gehst auf Kamps.de, gibst die Filiale ein und sagst, ich stehe gerade an der Kasse, tun Sie mir bitte schon mal zwei Buhl rustig und einen Granatsplitter und zwei Schokomuffins, bitte mal rein. Dann kommt so eine Chatnachricht, die zwei Weltmeister beruflichen liegen schon bereit. Fuck löschen, ab löschen, ab löschen. Und dann kannst du es abholen. Ist das nicht eine Möglichkeit? Super. Gibt es da nicht Synergieeffekte, die wir nutzen können? Genau wie beim Freizeitpark, das Virtual Queuing. Ja, oder Handzeichen, dachte ich auch, dass du wirklich wie so ein Flaggensystem, wie auf der Seefahrt, dass du wirklich hast so zwei Franzbrötchen mit Apfel, dass du wirklich so und dann wird das alles schon vorbereitet und dann kannst du es mitnehmen. Kann man da nicht noch was machen. Super. Kann man da nicht noch was machen, mal an alle Einzelhandelfreunde. Ganz viel zu holen. So dass du während dem Warten das irgendwie nutzt für den anderen. Das leichteste war wahrscheinlich. Da muss ich sagen, ich bin sehr happy mit meinem Rewe, wo die Self-Checkout-Kassen immer zahlreicher werden. Ja, ja, ja. Inzwischen bei acht oder sowas. Ja, ja, ja, ja. Ich das ist ein kleiner Rewe mit acht Self-Checkout-Kassen. Und was die jetzt gemacht haben ist, die haben die noch getrennt zwischen Self-Checkout-Kassen, die nur bargeldlos und manche mit Bargeld funktionieren.
Das heißt, da selbst die langsamen Self-Checkout-Leute habe ich jetzt auch aus dem Weg.
Oh, phantastisch, phantastisch. Ich kann immer einfach durchgehen. Supergut.
Da bin ich echt neidisch. Das ist das ist wirklich das ist ganz toll und das will man doch auch ich sehe nämlich ja jetzt fast wieder mal in der schlange zu stehen okay weiss er bei mir kommt jetzt wieder momente des durchatmen genau dieses entschleunigens dieses wo man auch schon die die airpods raus hat und mal mit sich und seinen Gedanken allein hat. Ja, das stimmt. Das sind ja fast Momente, die ich mir jetzt hersehne mit meinem hypermodernen Lifestyle. Ja. Ich freue mich ja auf die Bäcker-Schlange. Das sind ja Momente, wo man wirklich Menschen auch mal hautnah erlebt. So, haben sie eine Payback-Karte? Nein. Das sind ja auch Gespräche, die einem wirklich auch nahe gehen und wo man jemanden wirklich kennenlernt und man wirklich einen Moment der Menschlichkeit auch hat in so einem kalten Alltag. Das sind ja auch wirklich. Bei Payback muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, habe ich, glaube ich, verschlafen. Wie viele Payback-Punkte hättest du haben können in deinem gesamten Leben? Damit sollten die eigentlich Werbung machen, dass die Payback wirklich so ein Riesenbanner und da will ich so 16 Millionen Payback-Punkte hätten sie bis jetzt haben, wenn sie schon vor einem Jahr angefangen hätten. Und mir ist völlig egal, was das ist, aber ich will 16 Millionen haben. Egal wovon, ich will das haben. Was da Leute sparen, weil sie ihre Daten in die Welt schreien. Ganz ehrlich? Hey, okay.
Ich will keine Payback-Punkte, ich will auch keinen Kassenzettel.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wann es angefangen hat,
dass Kassierer so penetrant sind mit dem Kassenzettel ständig.
Muss man geben.
Ja, das habe ich mir nämlich gedacht, dass man ab einem gewissen Punkt
und wirklich, ich kaufe mir meine vier Weintrauben und ein Kinder-Country
und es so, keine Kassenzettel, warum?
Warum soll ich da eine Dokumentation haben wollen?
Du schießt in der Küche mit deinem Knoblauchzeh und dann hinter dir steht dieser Rewe-Mitarbeiter. Sie haben den Kassenzettel vergessen. Ihr Mentos, ihr Kassenzettel. Die junge Dame hat die Mentos vergessen. Danny nimmt die Verfolgung auf. Junge Dame, nicht so schnell, hier Mentos.
Er,
ohne ihn zu kennen und ihm zu nahe treten zu wollen,
hat das Potenzial,
zu einem Weltmeisterproblem zu werden.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Er wirkt in seiner ganzen
sagen wir mal, Vehemenz
und Lebensfröhlichkeit
und
Serviceorientiertheit so wie jemand, der sich merkt, was ich kaufe immer und mich dann als Introvert zum Feind macht. Ja, absolut. Aber Mentors sind ganz geil eigentlich. Also ich habe die lange verschmäht, aber eigentlich sind die nicht schlecht. Nee, komm. Nee? Kommt bei mir nicht an. Nee, gar nicht? Ich habe die letzten so gefunden, die haben nicht mir gehört, aber die lagen da so rum. Hör auf, Dinge zu essen von Fremden. Und dann habe ich mir so genascht und dann dachte ich, vielleicht war es das auch, was es auch besser gemacht hat, der verbotene Aspekt, dass es nicht mir gehört hat, sondern man es geklaut hat, so von unter der Hand, von irgendwo.
Angenommen, du bist bei einem Kumpel zu Hause und da liegt so eine offene Packung Mentos rum und du so, nehm mir mal eine. Aber die, die normalen? Ja. Ich meine, das ist ja so, das Ding ist ja von Mentos die Idee, dass du deinen Atem erfrischst, wo man sich natürlich die Frage stellt, Irgendwann gab es Lakritzentos, wo ich immer gedacht habe, ist das ein Upgrade zu meinem aktuellen Mundgeruch oder ist es vielleicht sogar ... Knoblauch-Mentos wäre dann ... Oder ist es vielleicht sogar Downgrade? Also es gibt ja eine Skala von Mundgerüchen, muss es ja irgendwo geben. Die muss ja irgendwo rumliegen. Also im Mentos-Headquarter oder wo auch immer, aber irgendein Labor, muss es ja ... Was sind priorisierte Mundgerüche? Und ganz oben ist Pfefferminz, willst du immer haben, schlägt alles. Aber dann ist die Frage, wenn ich jetzt gerade einen Apfel gegessen habe und jemand bietet mir Kirschkaugummi an, ist das wirklich noch ein Upgrade? Ist das ein Upgrade oder ein Downgrade? Muss man dann überlegen. Hunde sollen Sellerie bekommen, damit sie einen guten Mundgeruch haben. Wirklich? Ja, das ist deren Mentos. Das ist auch eine Stange. Gebt Hunden Sellerie, die lieben das. Ihr Sellerie! Hunde lieben Sellerie, essen sie gerne, es ist super gesund und danach riechen sie angenehm aus dem Mund. Es ist jetzt kein Mentosgeruch, aber es ist ein Riesenupgrade zu allem, was Hunde sonst essen und wie sie aus dem Mund riechen. Das ist ein Maul, sorry. Da so viel Respekt, dass dann schon sein. Spannend, wie gut hat dein Knoblauch diese Ballen gerochen danach? Sehr gut, sehr gut. Ich mag das ja, vor allem, ich habe ja wirklich damit gearbeitet. Bist du ein Believer? Finger rein und so. Frischer Knoblauch stinkt nicht? Nee. Oder würdest du sagen, der stinkt auch? Ich finde, es stinkt ja der Reihe nicht so. Ich glaube, es gibt so Kombinationen. Also Knoblauch-Mayonnaise, finde ich, ist immer extrem hartnäckige Kombination. So Aioli. Oder wenn du halt einfach irgendwie so Pommes mit Ketchup, Mayo und Zwiebelstücken umdach. So Speziale. Speziale, weil er bleibt im Ganzen. Das ist ein Geruch, der bleibt wochenlang an den Fingern. Da musst du wirklich gucken, wie du weiterkommst. Aber habe ich jetzt auch für die Küche entdeckt, so einen Weg Handschuhe. Tatsächlich ganz gerne, wenn du so reinknetest oder so, kannst du das komplett wieder abstreifen, musst du nicht ständig die Hände waschen. Und ich überlege auch noch, einfach für den Alltag Einweg-Handschuhe einfach immer dabei zu haben. Einfach immer, wenn du in die S-Bahn gehst, U-Bahn. Der Weg geht ja weg von Einweg hin zum Mehrweg. Also einfach generell Handschuhe tragen. Ja. Einfach so Lederhandschuhe immer. Es ist ein Hygieneaspekt auch. Und halt die Fingerabdrücke. Das Leder kommt, weil hier ist nicht genau. Das kam mir zu schnell und das geht direkt in so eine Strangler. Der Hamburg Strangler. Richt, richter. Warum, also falls wir Strangler in den Hörern haben, warum wirkt ihr so gerne mit Lederhandschuhen? Also was ist es an Leder, das euch so würdig macht, also so ein Würgereflex hervorruft bei euch? Ich bin jetzt kein Fan von Serienmördern. Okay. Kein Fan. Jetzt streiten wir uns doch noch am Schluss. Wie cool wäre es, wenn gerade in Deutschland ein Serienkiller sein Unwesen treiben würde?
Das war ja meine grosse Prophezeiung.
2018, glaube ich, war das, sollten alle prophezeien, was das nächste Jahr bereithält.
Und ich habe gesagt, es gibt wieder einen riesigen Serienmörder.
Und dann kam Corona.
Und damit eine schöne Woche für mich. Es gibt wieder einen riesigen Serienmörder. Und dann kam Corona. Niemand hat eine Pandemie.
Und damit eine schöne Woche für mich.
Ja, ich lag daneben.
Nee, du lagst da.
Naja, weiss man denn um Serienmörder aktuell?
Nee, war nicht Covid der Serienkiller schlechthin.
Und das war's vom Podcast UFO für diese Woche.
Haut rein.
Wir hören uns nächste Woche wieder.
Bis dahin, macht's gut.
Wir heben ab.
Tschüss. Haut rein, wir hören uns nächste Woche wieder, bis dahin, macht's gut, weh, mach, tschüss!